[Musique]
quelle proportion des plantes
vasculaires qu'on trouve au canada est
exotique 28%
il y as au pays plus de 5600 espèces de
plantes connues et plus du quart n'est
pas originaire d'ici certaines comme la
marguerite et le pissenlit font
tellement partie du paysage qu'on les
croirait indigènes
pourtant elles sont arrivés ici avec les
colons européens
plusieurs comme le chardon deschamps ont
d'ailleurs fait le voyage
clandestinement leurs semences ayant
probablement été dissimulée dans un sac
degrés toutes les plantes exotiques ne
devienne pas envahissante
certaines se trouvent une niche au sein
d'un écosystème sans trop le perturber
mais quand elles prennent toute la place
et des loges la végétation indigène
elles deviennent alors envahissante et
nuisibles comme le phragmite ce rose ou
désormais omniprésent dans les fossés
agricole le long des routes et dans les
milieux humides
là où entre autres les quenouilles
dominait autrefois en zone agricole
les plantes exotiques envahissantes
peuvent être très problématique car elle
entre en compétition avec les espèces
cultivées pour l'eau la lumière et les
nutriments résultats les rendements
diminuent et le recours aux herbicides
lui augmente
quelques espèces exotiques nuit aussi à
la santé c'est le cas de la berce du
caucase qui provoque des brûlures
sévères comme une grande proportion de
plantes venues d'ailleurs
la berce a été introduites
volontairement par des horticulteurs qui
appréciaient sa beauté même si
l'éradication de toutes ces indésirables
et bien souvent impossible
apprendre à les reconnaître et déjà un
bon premier pas car plus on intervient
tôt plus on pourra freiner leur
propagation